LETITIA WRIGHT
The detail. The colors.
The beauty, the integrity.
Absolute integrity with Ruth Carter.
RUTH E. CARTER
Wakanda itself is such a concept.
We really wanted to come back to it.
This film gives you more.
More military, landscapes, cultures,
technology that's upgraded.
And much more M'Baku.
[M'Baku yelling]
RYAN COOGLER
Ruth Carter really just took that initiative
and pushed the film farther than I could
ever imagine. I just kind of keep my eyes
and ears open to the
brilliance of her bringing it to life.
RUTH E. CARTER
We want to present the Wakanda that
people know, and the Dora Milaje were
a big part of that Wakandan culture.
We also wanted to upgrade
their armor and give them
the ability to swim in that costume.
So, we had to create the new Dora Milaje.
ANGELA BASSETT
Ruth is giving us PhD, graduate,
beyond, beyond level. The embroidery,
the jewelry, the capes, the headdress.
She just took it up a notch.
QUEEN RAMONDA
Everyone seems to be working diligently.
ANGELA BASSETT
Ruth will exhaust every possibility,
in terms of her research,
to build this world of Wakanda.
And not just Wakanda this time,
now the Talokan.
NAMOR
My people call me K'uk'ulkan,
but my enemies call me Namor.
RUTH E. CARTER
We are all trying to make this as accurate
as possible,
but we are creating a subculture.
The Talokanil, they lived underwater
for thousands of years.
So, we went from historical
reference to imagination.
LETITIA WRIGHT
It's beautiful to see Ruth really go
the extra mile and
get that resource,
get that knowledge
and infuse it into this film.
LUPITA NYONG'O
Working with Ruth is really fascinating
because she's the calmest creator I know
and she's so humorous and light as she's
creating these really intense costumes
that are going to inform cosplay for
a decade to come
or more, you know?
RUTH E. CARTER
To come back to Wakanda,
to be able to present African culture in
a futuristic way that was not colonized,
is certainly a highlight of my career.